is there so we've been talking a little
bit about cryptocurrency but
is there spaces where this kind of
blockchain ideas that you're describing
which i find fascinating uh do you think
they can revolutionize some other
aspects of our world
that's not just money a lot of things
are going to be
revolutionized is uh is uh independent
of finance
by the way i really believe that
finance is uh an incredible form of
freedom i mean
if i free to do anything i want but i
don't even mean to do anything that's a
bad idea so i really think the financial
freedom
is very very important but you know but
you just i can say that you know
against you know censorship you write
something of a chain and now nobody can
take it out you can't
take it out that is a very important way
to express you know
our view and um and then the
transparency that uh
that you give because everybody can see
what's happening on the blockchain
so transparency is not money but i
believe
the transparency actually is a very
important ingredient
also of finance let's put it this way
as much as i'm enthusiastic about
blockchain and
decentralized finance um
and that we have actually our expression
we're trying to recreating with the
future five because
as much as we want to do we must agree
that
the first guarantee of financial growth
and prosperity are really the legal
system
the courts because we may not think
about them and say oh
of course a kind of a bunch of boring
lawyers but without them i'm saying
there is no certainty there is no
um notion of equality there is no notion
that you can
resolve your disputes thing that's what
thrives the commerce and things
and so what i really believe that the
blockchain actually
makes a lot of this trust essentially
automatic by make it
impossible to cheat in the way you don't
even need to go to court
if nobody can change a villager right
so essentially is a way of
you cannot solve when the legal system
reduces to a blockchain but what i'm
saying a big
chunk of it can actually be guaranteed
and there is no reason why technology
should be antagonistic
to legal scholarship it could be
actually coexisting
and one should start to doing the
interest things that the economy alone
cannot do
and then you go from there but but i
think that is uh
essentially is uh blockchain can affect
all kinds of our of our behavior yes in
some sense the
transparency the required transparency
ensures honesty
prevents corruption so there's a lot of
system that could use that and the legal
system is one of them
you